sehr geehrte Damen und Herren zu Hause
geschätztes Soldaten ich darf Sie recht
herzlich zur Angelobung der Rekruten des
einrückungstermines jänner 2022 der
zweiten Garde Kompanie begrüßen sie
sehen am linke Flügel eine
Ehrenformation gestellt durch die
Gardemusik und die vierte Garde Kompanie
192 Anzüge lobende Rekruten der zweiten
Garde Kompanie bilden die Front-
ich darf in den kurz den Ablauf näher
bringen in Kürze erfolgt das
ankündigungssignal die folgt von der
Meldung des gesamtkommandierenden an den
Militärkommandanten von Wien Herrn
Brigadier Magister Kurt Wagner
nach dem Abspielen der Bundeshymne und
dem Abschreiten der Front folgt die
Flaggenparade
damit der Führung beauftragte Kommandant
der Garde Oberstleutnant Thomas
gütersberger bitte Begrüßung der
Ehrengäste durchführen und nach einem
Choral hören wir die Worte der
Geistlichkeit
mag der Ansprache des
Militärkommandanten und einem Musikstück
hören Sie die Worte des Abgeordneten zum
Wiener Landtages und Vertreter des
Bürgermeisters von Wien Herrn Magister
Markus Schober
eine Fanfare leitet zum eigentlichen
Höhepunkt dieser Veranstaltung dem
Treuegelöbnis über
den Abschluss bildet das Musikstück oder
meine Österreich und das erbitten
weitere Befehle nach dem Abrücken der
Ehrenformation endet die feierliche
Angelobung
[Musik]
das ganze
schon
ehrenkomponie presseniert
das ganze recht schaut
[Musik]
eine Ehrenkompanie sowie unter 192
anzugehen ohne Rekruten zur feierlichen
Angelobung angetreten
danke
[Musik]
das ganze
hab acht
[Musik]
Ehrenkompanie
Pressen wird
das ganze recht schaut
[Musik]
das ganze
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der zweiten grade-companie meine
jüngsten Soldaten
ich darf Sie heute hier begrüßen in der
Maria theresien-kaserne nach doch
fordernden Wochen am Truppenübungsplatz
Bruckneudorf und ich hoffe
dass das heute die letzte Angelobung und
der Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit ist
dass wir dann in Zukunft wieder
Angehörige zu dieser Veranstaltung
einladen dürfen was natürlich eine
besondere Aufwertung für die Anzug
genommen Rekruten darstellen wird es
sind trotzdem einige Ehrengäste heute so
angelogen erschienen und ich darf an der
Spitze besondere Gäste heute begrüßen
nämlich eine Delegation des serbischen
sicherheits- und
Verteidigungsausschusses des Parlaments
stellvertretend darf ich den Botschafter
seine Exzellenz ja
herzlich willkommen
die Vertretung ist Bürgermeisters von
Wien darf ich den Herrn Abgeordneten zum
Landtag Magister Markus Schober begrüßen
mein willkommensgruß
ein aufrichtiges und herzliches Grüß
Gott und bitte ich den Vertretern der
militärgeistlichkeit
jetzt Priester Vater Alexander lappin
von der orthodoxen Militär Seelsorge und
die islamische mit der sieht sogar
erkennen
im Vertretung der Frau
Bezirksvorsteherin unseres
heimatbezirkes Hietzing darf ich den
stellvertretenden Bezirkskommandant
der zweiten Kompanie
wie schon erwähnt liegen doch fordernde
Wochen hinter ihnen sie sind quasi
durchs regelfeuer gegangen und werden
sich hoffentlich dadurch die Hölle
ersparen sie werden in ihren
verschiedenen Funktionen Dienst versehen
egal in welcher Funktion sie dann ihre
Dienste fortsetzen
ist die
Leistungsbereitschaft und die bereits an
erzogene und angelernte Disziplin
wesentlicher Bestandteil für ihren
erfolgreichen Beitrag im
österreichischen Bundesheer
wie so viele Kameraden vor ihnen schon
bei der Garde und im österreichischen
Bundesheer gewinnt haben jetzt sind sie
an der Reihe
für meine
gardesoldaten wird es eine überaus
interessante aber auch fordernde
Ausbildung geben
und ich bedanke mich bei allen Kameraden
der zweiten Jahre company für die bisher
gezeigte Leistungsbereitschaft und
wünsche Ihnen für die weitere Verwendung
und für die weitere Ausbildung viel
Soldaten Glück
[Musik]
sehr geehrter Herr Botschafter Exzellenz
Werte Delegation
in nicht einfachen Zeiten unserer
gemeinsamen europäischen Heimat
Herausforderungen Entwicklungen die auf
uns alle wirken und wirken werden es
braucht den Schutz des allmächtigsten
Gottes von oben und in dieser Stunde
darf ich Ihnen wo Sie das Gelöbnis
sprechen werden auf unsere Republik und
diese Republik auch entsprechend zu
verteidigen den Schutz von oben zu
bitten wir
Herr du kennst unsere Schwäche
du weißt wie leicht wir den Mut
verlieren du weißt wie ängstlich wir
unsere Schritte setzen
aber du hast uns gerufen
darauf verlassen wir uns
wir wissen nicht ob etwas herauskommt
bei allem was wir in deinem Namen tun
aber das Werkzeug braucht sich nicht zu
ängstigen um den Sinn des Werkes du hast
uns in die Hand genommen
brauche uns
ich wünsche Ihnen allen Gottes Schutz
Gottes Segen führen dienstvoller
Herausforderungen liebe Kameraden der
sie in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
erwarten wird gott schütze sie
Idee Miley
alles Gute
sehr geehrte Gäste aus Serbien Werte
Kameraden sehr geehrte Kommandanten
Liebe an so gelobende
ich darf Ihnen denn für heute
ausgelosten
Bibelvers Vorlesen aus dem Propheten
Jesaja 25 Vers 8
und ihn in den mitgeben in die auf sie
zukommende Zeit der Herr wird aufheben
die Schmach seines Volks in allen Landen
wir sind hier beim Propheten Jesaja an
einer Stelle wo er in die Zukunft schaut
dass das kommen wird und die Erlösten
werden dankeslieder singen und Gott wird
etwas Besonderes tun er wird die Hülle
entfernen die Decke wegnehmen die
Menschen aus allen Völkern werden kommen
und überall werden sie Gottes
Herrlichkeit sehen können und dann der
Bibelvers er wird aufheben die Schmach
er wird die Tränen von allem
Anwesenden
abwischen viel wird geschehen aber es
steht immer noch aus
im Gottvertrauen dürfen wir darauf
hoffen dass es früher oder später
geschehen wird er wird befreien er wird
die Decke wegziehen und alle werden
begreifen und sehen wer ist nämlich Gott
und dieses Gottvertrauen
[Musik]
möchte ich Ihnen auch zusprechen und
ihnen mitgeben
dass Gott Gott ist
wenn ich an die Grenze komme und Besuch
mache
bei den Posten dann werde ich auch gerne
gefragt ob ich Dienstaufsicht mache und
ich sage dann ich bin wegen ihrer
Seeligkeit heraus
und das meint so viel wie dass wir
gemeinsam auf Gott vertrauen auf ihn
hoffen können dass er gut ist und man
muss nahe ist